rolou a bola para o lado pessoal de quem
fala é dar que sejam muito bem vindos
que mais 1 e e1 estragos e que o jogo de
terror que não é um jogo normal não está
um judeu uma bola mal ultimamente só
fala mesmo na internet porque não sabe
que é momo é noé pois aqui é isso possa
manter uma lenda urbana é um espírito
que anda por aí contactar as pessoas não
é de saber se vocês mandaram uma
mensagem pra ela baixo poder de volta e
supostamente uma coisa assombrada sei lá
inclusive eu já tentei contactar amon
mas não teve resposta então basta porque
não gramacho isso russo aleksei eu soube
que não ia ter resposta polícia andréia
sementeira não me revejo será que existe
pessoal
será que não existe como embaixo que
você já acha que independentemente se
ela existe ou não eu achei que o jogo do
morumbi tour mas militar com ninguém e é
precisamente isso vamos jogar agora
pessoal portanto fiquem atentos à
companhia por vai ter muitas têm buscado
muita coisa aqui e se vocês são nossos
aqui no canal pessoal saber se o vosso
voto inscrição já se inscrevam aqui no
canal pessoal desse tamanho muito mais
que antes de praticar os 60.000 50m
light ok quando uma ciência e para lá
então jogaram em um jogo da mola espera
que os joguinhos que o pessoal faz assim
yunet calmamente não dá para fazer 100
jogos sim dos então o jogo vai ser muito
podre mas ao mesmo tempo estou no
entanto vamos jogar jogar jogar esta
espanhol e chuteira espanhol louca e eu
te ver o texto e mirando não é igual a
bater na porta traseira aberta não é
comigo não reconhece as folhas chamar a
polícia
nó no lago cerqueira e mal não sabe que
estou chamando a polícia é meu primeiro
ano no momento declarei um contínuo
palavra curtida também gravando e eu já
está acesa porque está contigo sobrevive
até na polícia e e até então tem que
sobreviver até reduzir chega tão longe e
viu uma porta mas como é que eu já
paguei o fim da tarde e vai ficar aqui o
vídeo é pra ser um luxo é pra pagar num
não funciona o jogo não está a funcionar
em itu a moçambique manter não há há há
assim como é que esta porta aberta como
é que essa porta fecha a porta quando é
que isto porque já estava aberto
impossível é bom é nec flaw é que onde
ela nesta casa abandonada está uma casa
abandonada e voltar a saltar pela janela
o um amigo na briga eu posso falar que
falta mesmo é que o lado bom é que eu
vou fugir vou fugir custo do jantar é
uma casa muito com a cidade velha mesmo
entrou só o que posso esconder debaixo
da cama não dá isto funciona o máximo
que eu posso fazer isso é pagar a luz é
o máximo que eu posso dizer que investiu
e abrir janelas que apanhar aquela briga
está claro fresco é que eu quanto os
estados mesmo eu estou apostando em uma
casa da idosa passou por aqui mas
ninguém possa ter e eu não sou ninguém
superou uma luz eu não existe neste
momento é uma lanterna que só flutua
pela casa e gostoso não faz idéia é sua
ajuda e deixe muito laquê que nesse
critério porque eu sei que você está
muito isto é um bis qualquer stonehill
pleno esplendor inep não é um frei
steelman mo porta encontrou uma chave já
vi é para apanhar chapa eu vou jogar o
jogo
mo loló
deus mandou que ela vai opera berta
pausa para o mundo para o mundo avião
para no ar carro pára na estrada para
tudo o que eu não venho eu não veio não
gostaria de falar agora é se eu já tinha
a casa já tinha aqui o primeiro dado o
papel e amigo
vocês viram a pata de galinha é mesmo
igual amor
já no rio não tiver outra memória agora
eu sei que em cima de um só tom então eu
já sou só acompanhar chave porque se
chama vai dar acesso a qualquer porta eu
não saio por aí assim o jec não estamos
indo termos de letra de pastores não
posso não dá pra entender esse que o
mato é um crime isso ocorra é preciso
apenas que estava muito bem tinha um
chavão emitir 1
não sei falou ela vem sempre livre
cozinha testemunho do amor foi instalado
nó do ensino acho que estão em cima do
nó amistoso e agora como é que eu vou
estar lá ao salvar minha direção eu
cuido em treinamento desportivo da minha
procura vou ficar aqui no escuro e é
simplesmente barulho na unic brutal
mandato já de machava aproveitar essa
chave de simples ao bloco em você tem no
máximo estou com fome né meu máximo
porque vocês vão conseguir porque o
estoque está é porque tem passos têm que
seguir serra não tem barulho esquema do
esporte ela tem tudo aqui ontem jatos
foram bigode
eu acho que está seguro possa lançar
barulho dela é na mão assim tá
olha-se taxas dentro da capital segue o
jogo
assim do gerador trepado atrapalhado que
isso gênero no cinema tal geradora
tapado e nem dá para acender as luzes da
banda
eu não vim eu estava mesmo no outro lado
da porta do cinema está mais difícil do
que o guarani
é muito mais difícil então eu sou muito
burro está eu sei que o senhor
vamos lá pra mim agora aproveitar
enquanto a luz agora é deixar a casa
deixa eu vou tentar ser constrangedor
equipe
a última casa da mãe já estava perto
todo discutindo consignado não está
mesmo aqui em baixo mas não dá pra ficar
e valeu a ilha a monobóia nonô do
tucanato bordel de luxo fica aqui é que
agora dá só fica é qual é assim jogo
muito complicado não dá pra andar aqui
na casa tem moral nem todo lado é muito
grande tem pata de galinha não
conseguirá esta série fallen possível eu
vou ser muito curioso para mim coragem
em que na área
ela tava lá embaixo a sair aí e eu vou
aproveitar que a luz já tinha outra vez
como fiz há pouco que eu voltar a sentar
no chão em um rancho de mandar ou não já
que seja um líder não pode ser meu plano
ela vai na porta da rua ela vem daqui só
confirmar seu saque
agora eu já sei o que estou fazendo
errado aqui agora é outro momento
quer outra vez mas pede agora que o
habilita a esta casa
no caso do banco do brasil em campo aqui
tenho aqui que tudo aqui não é como
estar aqui como ela sabia e um cinema um
w para isto agora vai querer agora estou
sentindo eu sentir sempre nunca vai se
encontrar nesta porta do carro fura o
pulso da folha da casa
sua alta enquanto é um novo uma nova
forma de jogar este ano o lucro o que eu
acho que consegui entrar aqui
ele precisa chave do sol tão precária e
é isso que eu tenho de ir ao sótão
buscar a chave para abrir esta porta que
isso é inédito de s
agora é só ir lá pro fofa mas acho que o
que tem que fazer com que nossa campanha
não só fica pra baixo pra rua entrar
dentro do estábulo com essa chave que
ver o que tem lá dentro vamos fazer isso
ok nós estamos cá fora já tem chave e
agora que eu vou descobrir seu saber
para quem eu não os quero que seja meu
deus deu muito trabalho mesmo o um
pouquinho machado
eu consigo mas agora será conseguir matá
la
e agora o que eu faço como é que eu
achava eu não consigo
só assim será eu não sei que somos temos
mais uma batalha longa high eu vou matá
la e levar em 1868 fugir na moto
a pessoa vai ser uma animação wall e
mataram um aluno
como a que está a morrer tom quase isso
assim assim
depois de muita resiliência depois de
muita persistência
depois de muita dedicação esforço
trabalho nós conseguimos pessoal
destruir amor portanto já sabem se mais
alguém fizer algum vídeo é mostrar que
está a contactar a momo é mentira eu já
matei a comprovada que e mas só pra ter
um destaque deste vídeo já saem sul nove
no canal de escravos subestação no vídeo
deixei muito aqui e você pode trazer
mais vídeos de touro e enquanto como
suponho fiquem bem até aproximar